the succession War just seriously amped
up karapika is back at the Helm of the
series and yes there's a whole ton of
Princess happening here you know
politicking and scheming and intriguing
and look don't quite worry if you're not
following along because a lot of what's
Happening Here is an escalation of
material that was put to Paige like four
years ago so I will clarify and
contextualize everything because what is
happening right now is so damn exciting
also Hunter Hunter's next Hiatus has
been announced but don't despair because
this announcement actually came with
some exceptionally good news which I
will get to later but we initially kick
off with a crossover troop scene
directly picking up from the last
chapter on the hunt for the Haley it's
quite bittersweet because it seems like
this is the last we'll be seeing of that
story thread for a while because the
rest of the chapter goes pretty balls
deep back into Prince territory but
Vince and feitan had a fun little
exchange regarding n essentially the
idea that using n in a crowded place is
just a bad idea because while it spreads
your aura giving you all of the
informations it also alerts any other
net user to your presence and thus makes
you a pretty big Target the reason why
this is relevant though is because we
seem to be implying that Finks has quite
a wide range of n because the Haley bass
is anywhere from 100 to 200 meters away
on the radar and according to Nobunaga
way back in chapter 94 the range of
someone who has mastered and tends to be
around the 50 meter Mark but that is for
someone who has seriously honed their
nandcraft not just any old scrub can
reach that Mark and it would seem that
Finks is a bit above average in this
particular area however it comes with
problems he can spread his Aura quite
far I guess but he seems to lack the
concentration to keep it up which is one
of those things that really puts into
perspective just how much of an end God
xeno's older is as he can extend his end
up to 300 meters and then you have just
stupid existences like Pito who can
extend up to two whole kilometers also
this video is sponsored by raid Shadow
Legends The Game featuring over 650
unique champions from different factions
to collect and collect I shall because
we are gonna crack some sacred shots so
these give us epic or Legendary
Champions and Bam look at that is a
clawed the Beast feeder well equipped
with beasts that I imagine is going to
be fed potentially to another beast and
we have a uh well we have a
miscellaneous elf dude that looks cool I
suppose but this is what I'm talking
about it's a big old bear I love it he's
he is my new favorite everything also
raids just released a legendary champion
based off MMA and pro wrestling Legend
Ronda Rousey and you can get Rhonda for
free simply by playing raid for seven
days between now and February 20th plus
Amazon Prime members can get their
exclusive rewards in raid right now also
use the promo code raid Rhonda to get a
ton of helpful stuff like a three-day
100 XP boost 500k silver and 5 energy
refills and there's more new players use
my link or scan the QR code to get a
free starter pack worth almost 30 a free
champion owner and this cool in-game
loot you'll find your rewards here on
your inbox for the next 30 days on so do
that thing but for now it's back to you
me but Nobunaga then catches up with
them because apparently Finks and fate
ended practically nothing while he was
away but they ascertain a bit of a bit
of a Twist here being that the Haley
Base is almost certainly on tier 2 which
I like because it gives us a good reason
to get in and explore that final tier
and I also think it's great writing on
the part of Togashi who constantly has
his characters referring to the hilly
conflict as a bit of a side quest with
the main plot of course being to reach
hisoka but the way it's weaved is quite
brilliant because in order to reach
hisoka on the upper tears we do first
need to complete this side quest to
secure passage to those levels and it
makes me wonder if this was the actual
goal of both the GU and Chara families
to begin with when it came to hisoka
they said they wanted to find him to
preserve balance but what's actually
happened is that they've placed hisoka
in an unreachable location one of their
practically dangling in front of the
Phantom troop in order to ensure that
they fight the Haley it's quite clever
because otherwise no one would care and
they would just head straight for the
main story Nobunaga also suggested that
they bring Franklin which yes that is an
amazing idea good good thinking Mr
Samurai man because thinks fatan and
Nobunaga are the exact wrong troop
members to try and bust into the space
but then there's the emergency broadcast
and I think this is what's going to
haunt me most of all while we're on
break because that touch of thing is
just such a kick in the nuts kind of
cliffhanger something very bad has
likely happened on tier three and we we
just won't know what it is for a long
time to come because even with the next
batch of chapters we've clearly shifted
away from the mafia plot so that's
that's just wonderful tagashi thank you
throwing ourselves merciles back into
kakin politics we pick up with the
prince plot of six Prince Tyson who if
you've forgotten is the cult leader who
plans to win the contest with her
teachings of love and and just love so
here's the thing this whole section was
really sweet we get an introduction to
Tyson's quirky role-playing bodyguards
and izunavi sees a win condition for the
contest and we even have this profound
moment of very empathetic introspection
for Tyson herself and I trust absolutely
none of it I think what we're seeing
here is Tyson's charm at work people
eventually succumb to her if they spend
enough time around her and izunavi is
crumbling and playing right into Tyson's
hands because by the end of this section
he is practically begging Tyson to have
her teachings read at the banquet in
front of the king he's an obvious
thinking is that this wall could
probably be won quite peacefully if
everyone just gets converted to the
teachings of Tyson however I think that
Tyson's teachings might be starting to
inform his thinking even though he
hasn't read the book yet to the best of
our knowledge because izanavi's entire
rock on this ship has been him and the
other guy just trying to resist reading
the book of Tyson the other guy being
Giuliano by the way who crumbled like a
[ __ ] and is now a full-on Tyson convert
but that book is only one part of
Tyson's inherent manipulation and look I
don't know it just strikes me as
interesting that izanavi is now actively
fighting to spread the gospel of Tyson
he's become a sort of unwilling disciple
but next we cut back into what's
happening in the sphere of 11th Prince
fugetsu and this is where things are
probably going to be most confusing for
those who haven't touched this Arc in a
long time alright wow where do we even
begin here because there are there are
so many different threads Crossing
through this path but the first woman we
see is Queen Seiko the mother of 10th
Prince can't show and 11th Prince
forgetsu and she seems to know that
kancho is dead nah that's interesting
because not even fugetsu knows that
can't show is dead and fugetsu was there
when Karcher did the dying meanwhile the
Kat show we do see in this chapter is
actually her guardian Spirit beast
called without you who took on kacho's
appearance after her death to continue
helping fugetsu who honestly at this
stage seems almost unhelpable because
skipping ahead a bit it is entirely
possible that she is going to be the
next Prince to die when Melody walks
past her she sees fugetsu covered in
these pretty disturbing Spirit dudes and
Melody equates fugetsu's status to an
almost state of zetsu meaning that her
Aura and therefore her life force is
bordering on undetectable now a big plot
point in this chapter going forward is
Melody trying to figure out which nasty
Prince is doing this to forget to
there's a bunch of interviews where
third Prince sang Lei shows up and like
not to derail this too much but that was
actually real surprising usually the
princess would send Gods to do this kind
of business for them but no not Zhang
lay dude just showed up and also Zangle
gave Melody one of his patented coins
these are produced by his Guardian
Spirit beast and we still have no
confirmation on exactly what they're for
Zangle himself seems to think that they
will only activate after he wins the war
and needs to distribute them for the
good of the Kingdom but his God had a
counter Theory which was that they could
be exchanged in some way for use during
the war in any case I don't want to get
too bogged down in nencoin just needed
to flag that Melody is now an investor
in nencoin and that could be a very
important plot point in the future but
as for which Prince did this this this
this to forget to a lot of trouble
saying that but I am 99 certain that
this is the work of Camilla and more
specifically her Legion of Have Nots
this is the group of nen curse users who
spend months or even years thinking
about their target I suppose charging
the curse before one day committing
suicide in order to enact the curse and
from there that targets Aura is just
drained rapidly until a state of death
is achieved so they kill them and it has
been stated that in some cases if the
curse prep is strong enough then a
Target can die within mere hours fugetsu
here has deteriorated within a few days
but everything still lines up pretty
perfectly with all the cursed business
of the have-nots and I guess the
particularly spooky thing is that
fugatsu may not have just one curse
because cause there's like 10 men
Spirits surrounding her draining that
life force which is ever so important
for life and so it could be a whole
Legion of curses that have struck all at
once to ensure her death and if that is
the case then I don't think there is
anything that can be done to save her
however if it's just one curse then
maybe you just need to find an an
exorcist except that's a problem because
the only Nan Exorcist we know about
aboard the black whale 1 also belong to
Second Prince Camilla's faction so I
could be wrong but right now my money is
on Prince Camilla being The Mastermind
here and I don't feel too great for the
future of fugetsu unless karapika can do
something which he may because Melody is
kind of summoning him she's sending out
the karapika signal at the end of the
chapter but unless he can do something
fugetsu is without a doubt the next
corpse to go into nasibi's burial
chamber but also Melody has her own
problems to deal with because right now
the entirety of Tier 1 is aware of her
none ability and just how useful it is
for various day-to-day activities like
say assassination and as a result she
has a lot of princes interested in her
including a certain seradnik which is
always is disconcerting and it's really
not a good position to be in at all
because it will start out very civilized
with each prince trying to court Melody
to their side however the prince is also
know just how much of a threat Melody is
if she's not on their side which could
lead to an understandable desire to
eliminate her and this whole situation
is also a pretty extreme perversion of
Melody's heartsu because the whole thing
was designed to heal people quite
literally it can cure some illnesses but
also to put the mid-ease and make ah
everything's nice now as opposed to
actual life but the potential of which
is seen by the princes as something of
an anesthetic I guess to put people
under in order to kill murder them and
then there's this guy kaizaru he plays a
very Central role in this chapter for a
guy that I honestly forget if he's ever
actually appeared before because this
chapter is coming out just before
Christmas I didn't quite have the time
to do the research that I would have
normally but he theoretically has no
Allegiance with the karkin Empire
however Melody suspects that kaizaru is
in League with one of the princes and
given the idea to assassinate each of
the top four and Melody's thinking that
it's unlikely to be one of of the
princes that tried to contact her which
apprentices one three four five and
seven then that would narrow our Prince
pull down to four of those four I would
personally eliminate Maryam and wobble
because they just don't have that kind
of influence due to the whole being a
child thing which leaves us with six
Prince Tyson and Ninth Prince hawkenberg
and either one of them could be it
perhaps kaizarro has been exposed to
Tyson's teachings or he may even be
politically aligned with hulkenberg's
vision or something like that that or
Melody's thoughts are wrong and it could
be something completely different
altogether but I'm less inclined to
believe that with Melody yes Togashi
does like to have logical characters
come to the wrong conclusions in
perfectly sound ways however Melody has
something of a cheat sheet for Hunter
Hunter her abilities are very much like
a roundabout way of mind reading so I'm
inclined to believe her conclusions much
more so than your average character
meanwhile the chapter ends as promised
with karapika taking the whole months
more and it showcases him agreeing to
work with fifth Prince to bappa's
faction which is immediately intriguing
because tobappa is also currently in
League with seradnik so helping her is
also very much further covering the
fourth Prince's agenda and as much as he
probably doesn't know this it's actually
bringing krapika himself closer to
saradny so this is a case where
karapagos kind of stumbled into helping
his most major enemy of the Ark which is
it's not a great place to be but this
also may be relevant because tobappa's
Guardian Spirit Beast is a collaborative
type it requires a quote research
partner to properly function so this
Alliance may even see that role expanded
upon however everything right now is
converging in on the top princes princes
1 2 and 3 in particular have everyone
Out For Blood against them however that
is assuming that the lower princes can
actually survive long enough to actually
get there to said blood which for quite
a few of them not looking great and
speaking of not looking great yes Hunter
Hunter is officially back on Hiatus
after chapter 400 however do not despair
because this isn't bad news at all in
the announcement they State the
intention is to be publishing hunter
hunter in a format that isn't weekly
going forward what that means is
currently up in the air could be monthly
I wouldn't mind monthly but they also
emphasize that Togashi is continuing
throughout the chapters so the
publication is on Hiatus but Togashi and
his assistants are continuing to work
which is so much better than any other
Hiatus announcement the announcement
also makes clear that the intention is
to support Togashi as best they can
until the completion of the manga I'll
say that again the completion of the
manga meaning that everyone's eyes are
on the prize of making sure that Hunter
Hunter actually finishes what world do
we live in without as a possibility so I
think this is amazing news and I would
expect to be now taking a couple of
months off maybe even a few months off
but we know that chapters 401 through
404 are already in production and have
in fact been in production for a while
so as painful as it is I don't think
that the wait will be too long this time
and they will of course keep you updated
with all of the hunter-based
developments as they become known